as country slowly begin to reopen their
economies big data is being used to help
prevent further spreading of kovat 19
one way is contact tracing the virus can
be kept in check by identifying new
positive cases then tracking down other
people those cases may have been in
contact with contact tracing can be done
manually over the phone by employing
lots of people or through smartphone
apps Apple and Google are working
together on improving their technology
to make it easier for contact tracing
apps to work more effectively but in
response to concerns around government
access to personal data and privacy
other organizations have stepped up with
solutions at their own doctor potion low
is a math professor at Carnegie Mellon
University and a Hertz foundation fellow
which is the network of scientists and
engineers who pledged to make their
skills available during national
emergencies he and his team came up with
the contact tracing app for Android and
iOS called no vid at the moment that you
installed the app we don't ask you for
anything no mobile phone number no email
address no name
not even a user name nothing actually
what happens is as soon as you install
it it generates a random number and that
random number is your user ID it
actually doesn't even tell you your user
ID so that you wouldn't be able to even
accidentally tell anyone else but that
user ID is the way that all of this
stuff is put together is that the server
collects all of this non personal data
such as somebody called user number 362
has alter-ego seven three five one and
that person was around alter-ego two one
six at 2:45 p.m. Eastern Time on April
28 2020 and the server has that and the
messages are very vague and well very
vague in the sense of making it very
difficult to track down who it was that
gave you a potential infection the
messages say things like somebody just
self-reported a positive test during the
time that they were potentially
contagious they spent at least half an
hour with you dr. Loe says what makes
Nova unique is the use of both Bluetooth
and ultrasound signals to determine past
contacts and his team also ruled out GPS
for privacy concerns we want to have no
GPS data so that even if somebody were
to force us to give and
information that we have we know nothing
about you then the other the other types
of technologies you could use are
Bluetooth which is very nice but as you
know if you have Bluetooth headphones
the Bluetooth signal strength is quite
strong and in fact you could even have
something that senses in another room so
we added ultrasound as well the reason
we added ultrasound is because
ultrasound does not go through walls and
also sort of like how sonar works you
can use ultrasound to determine how far
away something is by making a sound and
seeing when the other device here is it
guy Nakamura and his team at tracked
together are using data reporting and
symptom tracking to try and help
researchers and public health
departments including the UK's national
health service users fill out a basic
survey about their symptoms and the only
personal information they give is their
age and zip or postal code that data is
aggregated to determine what areas of a
country need the most help we're really
trying to keep it simple and allowing
people to report symptoms that don't
require official tests so it doesn't
give you a perfectly accurate picture as
to how far the virus has spread but it
will give health authorities and public
health experts some sorts of vague idea
of where the disease may have spread to
where they otherwise might not know
Nakamura says track together has also
partnered with both academic
institutions and celebrity athletes from
the Premier League and NFL to help
spread the word and convince more people
to report in he also believes the
minimal amounts of information collected
should help allay fears of privacy
breaches or data theft I think what
we've tried to do is really steer clear
of all the kind of very much
location-based data that contact tracing
apps are collecting so we don't
necessarily have have the same issues
that other apps might be facing from a
privacy perspective because we're not
monitoring every single movement that a
user takes I think that's really how
we're trying to steer clear of that
because we fundamentally believe the
simple data that we are collecting can
still drive to men's value globally and
locally in the case of data and
reporting some studies have found that
few people who self-report kovat 19
symptoms actually have the virus for
contact tracing apps
a big challenge is simply getting enough
of the population to sign up some data
modelers have said the ideal number is
60% of a population but that is
considered unrealistic in actual
practice to put it in perspective
Singapore has a population of about 5.7
million people with higher levels of
trust in government but also higher
amounts of government control and
surveillance than Western nations even
so only about 26% of the population have
downloaded its contact tracing